is the Apple watch Ultra 2 really worth
800 or should you just get a series nine
well today we're gonna compare
everything from the designs the displays
Comfort exclusive features and even
things like the microphones and the
speakers and I think you guys will
actually be quite surprised by some of
the differences now getting into the
packaging you guys could see that the
ultra gives you a nice big package here
if we open it up Apple did a really nice
job on the outside it looks very neutral
but in the inside you get this nice
adventurous print we have a really nice
booklet that they probably spent a lot
of money on I'm showing you all the
little features there and then we have
the separate packaging now this thing
comes with a different kind of loop I'm
gonna scoot this aside and let me show
you the series nine now this also has
some nice prints on the inside
everything's a little bit smaller now I
gotta say I've always been a fan of this
design and here I have the midnight
color and to me this seems quite small
even though it is a 45 millimeter just
because I've worn the ultra for a year
and I got a lot of kind of feedback for
you guys for the ultra there now pulling
out the charging cable this year even
the regular one comes with a nice
braided cable and then if I pull the
puck out here you do get a nicer
aluminum one instead of a plastic so
that is actually a nice little detail
now as far as the band I just have the
regular one here let's go ahead and open
it up and this is also a midnight now
Apple made this whole product carbon
neutral and it's actually maybe feels a
little nicer than the one last year let
me go ahead and put this on and see how
it pairs up now with the series 9 you
have a choice of five different colors
including the new pink color that I
thought my daughter would absolutely
love whereas with the ultra we still
have just one color natural titanium so
it literally looks identical to last
years but the great thing is that it is
very very resistant to scratches and if
you get something you're not going to
notice it like you do with the regular
Apple watches take a look at this
footage of my wife's and my son's
aluminum Apple watches they get gashed
and scratched like crazy they do not
stand up very well now if you get the
stainless steel like I've purchased in
the past well that holds up way better
it does get some scratches but of course
that costs so much money now with the
ultra after a year mine still look brand
new and so that is a really big selling
point now let me pull out the this
Alpine Loop right here this year I got
the color that I actually wanted and
these are designed for the ultra they
are more sporty and you have this hook
right here so once you tighten up the
actual band itself and put the hook in
this thing is not going anywhere now of
course there's also the Ocean band and
the trail one but none of them really
have a premium or a classy look now
regardless of whether you're upgrading
to a new Apple watch or not the band is
what shows off your personality and
style the most so what I have here are
the most popular bands from our sponsor
Nomad Goods including their sport band
with its rugged look as well as their
really nice premium genuine leather
bands for that classy look and finally
all out luxury with their titanium band
which perfectly matches the ultra tube
so go ahead and order a nomad band today
by using the links in the description
below and the first big difference that
you notice is the weight we have 38.8
grams compared to
61.4 and man that weight is there now I
will say after wearing the ultra for
three four days you just get used to it
um so if you get used to it that's not
that big of a difference but if you have
a smaller wrist or if you're smaller
framed that could make a difference even
compared to a 45 millimeter series nine
and the other thing you'll notice is the
thickness you guys could see that the
ultra 2 is so much thicker than the
series nine it is a huge difference and
even the sensors underneath stick out
more so now this is one thing that I
kind of got used to but not completely
because with this huge thing you will
hit things and sticks out more and even
sleeping for sleep tracking it is
nowhere near as comfortable as a series
nine so I pretty much stopped using the
sleep tracking function just because of
comfort wear with a regular Apple watch
it feels great and you almost don't feel
it there at all and with the ultra 2 I
have actually scratched different things
because of these really sharp edges for
example I showed off last year it
literally shreds off your fingernail if
you have an object like an iPhone it
literally scratches the back of this
metal whereas the series nine it is
smooth it's not going to cause any
damage to anything else even though it
can be damaged whereas the ultra super
durable but it could cause some actual
damage so it's kind of an interesting
thing there now in a positive note one
thing I love about the ultra is the fact
that you have this Crown guard with the
regular Apple watches I often found
myself accidentally turning on Siri by
pushing on this Crown that's exposed and
so that can be a little bit annoying at
times but this Crown guard helps to keep
that from happening both of the watches
have the same button Crown layouts so
you have two here and two here but the
ultra has it poking out a little bit and
that could definitely help if you're
wearing gloves or different sporting
kind of scenarios and the haptics in the
ultra are also a lot stronger I would
say maybe triple the power because of
the better motor inside so that is a
nice boost and then on the left hand
side we have the action button on the
ultra and by default ever it's set to
work out right now you can actually
change that we have that workout
stopwatch Waypoint backtrack dive
flashlight and you can actually use a
shortcut and I will say that that has
been really nice to have now if you
press and hold down on that you can
actually get the siren and this thing
gets incredibly incredibly loud and I
think Apple said what 600 feet awaken
here yeah crazy something crazy and with
that siren you also get dual GPS built
in and that is really nice because with
my kids Apple watches sometimes it will
just give me this big circle and I don't
know where my daughter is at or it will
actually show it in another spot and
then it'll bounce around so dual GPS
gives you much better accuracy the ultra
2 also gets a water temperature sensor a
depth gauge and a dive computer app
which is really cool but I don't use
that and the waterproofing is way better
as well it has military grade standards
but let's be honest most people aren't
buying it for that they are buying it
for the look and they are buying it for
the battery life the battery in the
ultra is much much bigger and because of
that instead of getting 18 hours of
battery life rated you get 36 and then
also in the low power mode it is way way
higher as well and in my previous
testing the OSHA could get me up to
three days of battery life in normal
usage compared to just one day now how
does that make sense that the battery
isn't triple the size well a lot of the
same tasks that it has to run in the
background they stay the same so you
just get way better battery life and
that's not only important right when
you're buying it because you could say
hey all-day battery life is enough but
once you've had it for a year or two
like my previous Apple watches the
battery capacity goes down and I've had
it where the Apple watch didn't even
last me all day and have to charge it
before the day is over so with the ultra
you could be confident that two years
later and three years later you're still
gonna have excellent battery life now
you may have noticed that the ultra has
a lot more little holes on the sides
than the series nine and that is because
it has triple microphones with beam
forming compared to the single
microphone on the series nine so let's
go ahead and test that this is the
microphone quality of the Apple Watch
series 9 in a normal scenario and this
is the microphone quality of the Apple
watch Ultra 2 in a normal room let me
know what differences you heard but I
also want to test out in a noisier
environment so I have loud restaurant
sounds opened up right here and let's
see how these compare this is the Micron
quality of the Apple Watch series 9 in a
noisy environment and this is the Micron
quality of the Apple watch Ultra 2 in a
noisy environment once again let me know
what differences you heard now along
with that we have a difference in
speakers the series knife has a single
speaker you guys see that little slit
right there where we have this huge
speaker Grille on the ultra 2 and it
actually has dual speakers built in so
let's go ahead and do a speaker test
[Music]
as you can hear the ultra 2 has louder
speakers now of course you're not going
to be listening to crab Rave but if
you're taking a phone call or using
walkie-talkie it's nice to have the
extra volume especially in louder
environments and now I need to talk
about the displays we have this 45
millimeter compared to 49 millimeter but
if we actually look at the pixel sizes
and the screen real estate you don't
actually get that much more with the
ultra 2 because the series 9 actually
curves around the edges of the display
so you have a thinner bezel compared to
the ultra which has a thicker bezel all
around as you guys see I just switched
that picture there but of course a lot
of the watch faces kind of hide that now
with the ultra you also get exclusive
watch faces like this new modular Ultra
and this thing gives you a ton of
different complications built in plus
you have some other ones as well so if
you like to have a lot of info on your
Apple watch while the ultra helps in
that regard now we also have a
difference in terms of screen brightness
the ultra 2 goes up to 3 000 nits now
compared to 2000 last year but we were
shocked that Apple put a 2000 in display
in the series nine that difference from
a thousand two thousand was huge last
year but this year 3000 it is brighter
but it was just fine before so that's a
positive for the series nine and last
difference I want to mention about the
displays is the durability with the
ultra you have a flat display and this
Edge actually protrudes a little bit and
that keeps it from cracking whatsoever
and of course with the design of the
series 9 where the glasses bent around
the corners it can break really easily
now if you spend more money you get the
stainless steel version instead of
getting the ion X glass on the aluminum
versions you will get sapphire glass
similar to the ultra drive and that
makes it way more durable but then of
course the price goes up by a ton and
this is where I have to get into pricing
a lot of people will say that the ultra
is very expensive eight hundred dollars
but the series nine well you can get
that for 3.99 half the price right well
at that price you have a smaller size
and you have an aluminum model without
cellular so if you bump up the size you
add cellular well you're already much
more expensive and then if you want to
go for a seamless steel for extra
durability you're at 750 bucks and if
you get a better band than the basic
cheap ones you're right there at 800 so
you really have to consider what kind of
upgrades you're gonna do and if you need
cellular because all of that's built
into the ultra 2 and then it might not
be much more expensive for a product
that is going to last a very long time
so with that said
should you get the series 9 or should
you get the ultra two well personally
even though I'm not somebody that's
going to go on crazy Adventures doing
crazy sport things I think the ultra is
a really great investment especially if
you upgrade your band from Nomad because
it makes it look much more classy
instead of just a sporty watch you get
the better battery life and you get so
many other great features built into it
that it's almost like a no-brainer as
long as you don't mind the extra kind of
size in bulk and personally I just got
used to it you let me know what you guys
end up deciding to go with go and click
that Circle above to subscribe check out
one of those great videos right over
there that's been Max and I'll see you
in the next one
[Music]